so first of all congratulations on your
new single this is your first
solo single called even the stars what
can you tell us about the song what's it
all about
um well i think the song and the reason
i was
so excited about it to begin with is
it's just a very aspirational song and
it feels like it just
fits in with the time that we're in and
sort of stating that
there are peaks and valleys and that's
just a part of life and
you know you need the dark times to
really appreciate the light and that's
something that i've always
um i've always believed and um
you know with my own ups and downs in
life and whatever that may be
that's always something i keep in mind
so yeah that's kind of what the song
encompasses i would say
now is this a song you've been working
on for a little bit was it during this
time how did it all kind of come about
um so rock mafia um who wrote
a queen of mean for me from the
descendants movies um
they actually approached me after the
surprising success of queen of mean
because it really it really kind of took
off and
i was so grateful and they approached me
and asked if i wanted to work together
again and
i mean they're so talented and they've
worked with so many incredible people i
just
was like yes obviously um so
they presented me with some songs and
i gravitated towards even the stars and
you know we worked to
make it fit my voice and you know they
were just really accommodating and um
yeah i i just i i loved it and
we we recorded it back in november so it
was some time ago
um but obviously the pandemic
happened and it kind of put things on
hold so
uh it's finally here it's been i feel
like i've been sitting on it for a while
but
i'm just happy to be able to share it
yeah now the music video dropped friday
what was it like for you shooting that
video because obviously there's a lot of
restrictions when it comes to filming
right now so what was it like kind of
shooting a music video under new
guidelines
so odd i mean i have actually shot i've
shot a couple music videos but
um this was definitely well first of all
it was
it was a much more intimate sort of
smaller scale
um especially compared to when i shot
queen of mean for
descendants which wasn't really a music
video but you know what i mean still a
musical number
um and it was just it was wild like
i think it's going to be quite an
adjustment for hollywood coming back
into
filming and and getting productions up
and running again it's just
so many safety protocols and you just
want to make sure everyone
feels safe um
and i i felt safe i know the crew did
felt safe and they did such an amazing
job
like face shield masks keeping six feet
apart the whole time it was like it's
pretty
pretty crazy but yeah definitely
interesting well the music video is just
so beautiful
how did you come up with the concept for
it and i absolutely loved your very
colorful shiny jacket
you like a multi-colored jacket i'm like
i want that right
that's my favorite look for sure that
you have so fun
um so we actually had
an entirely different concept pre-coded
yeah the director millicent hales who
did a such a fantastic job she actually
directed me through zoom
for um the music video she had this
this whole treatment planned and it was
kind of bigger and like we were gonna
have
dancers and such and then you know that
kind of got shelved and then she came
back with this
sort of revised idea that was a little
more simplified but i honestly think it
ended up fitting the song
so well um and it was just like we
wanted to keep it airy
and aspirational and kind of dreamy
um yeah which i i think i think we
achieved you know
like
just being outside and in nature
uh it definitely succeeded it was just
it was very whimsical too had like a
really beautiful feeling to it
yeah nice yeah now you said on instagram
that music's always been a source of
light for you so do you feel like you're
writing music especially kind of during
this challenging time when all of us are
at home right now are you getting some
inspiration
definitely i feel i mean i obviously
have
we all have so much time um right now
more than
for myself at least than i'm used to
yeah so
i have been writing a lot i love writing
poetry which i hope to turn into lyrics
um
and also writing uh
writing some songs and seeing where that
goes and hoping that i can take those
back to
um the team at rock mafia and see what
we can do with them but yeah
just trying to stay creative um because
that's
that gives me energy and such a big part
of my
life um yeah yeah i think it's important
during the time
now are you listening to some of your
favorite artists as well to kind of get
through some of the more challenging
days like who are your favorite artists
to listen to
right now oh gosh so many different ones
i
i right now i'm loving the band litany
they're kind of an alt
pop band um if you haven't heard of them
i would
definitely recommend them um and then
a lot of different rappers there's this
new upcoming rapper bibi no money who i
love
um canadian as well nice
yeah and i i'm kind of like i guess all
over the map like
selena i always play her when i'm just
like
getting ready or something um
rain on me it's like constantly blasting
i feel like
and i also like led zeppelin like i love
i love led zeppelin so
those are great that's great artist
great music i love it
it is it's a good variety mix yeah yeah
um is there an artist that you would
just absolutely
it would be a dream come true to be able
to collaborate with
yes i mean again i feel like there's so
many talented people out there i would
just like
just love to work with um just came to
mind now actually i feel like megan the
stallion would be so fun to work with
so cool it's so rad and so fun
and um yeah i just think she's awesome
and so that would be awesome but also uh
jennifer lopez like
i worked with her on a tv show so i
worked with her in that capacity but
doing music with her
would be a dream come true for sure
right so you played her daughter on
shades of blue right
yes so would you say that you know with
jennifer lopez being like
the dominating factor when it comes to
music when it comes to dance would that
be kind of like a career that would just
be a dream come true for you
absolutely i think she does everything
so well and she's so talented
and gifted in sort of every region
um and she's just like she's
her work ethic is like nothing i've ever
seen before so definitely inspiring and
you know when i was working with her i
was definitely taking notes yeah
um well obviously i want to talk to you
about charms
um the show has such an amazing
following
people are loving it um how much fun is
it for you being able to play a
character that's such a strong role
model for men and women out there
i mean it's it's it's all i could really
hope for you know i hope to do projects
that really
make a difference in someone's life
resonates and i hope
people see themselves on screen um and
you know being biracial i i feel very
lucky to be at
you know the forefront of a show with
two other women of color um
so that that for me is like like that's
peak like that's that's what i've always
wanted um
and then i just i love my character
maggie because she's
she's girly and she loves fashion but
she's also just
really smart and caring and empathetic
and i think
it's important to realize you can be
both of those like they're not mutually
exclusive i think there's this
misconception where like you
you love makeup and you love fashion so
you're
i don't know i don't know less
intelligent i don't know why that's the
conception
but um but no you can be you can be
multiple things and that's kind of what
maggie is
i love that um so do you miss your
co-stars do you miss kind of being on
set with everybody
i do i i mean i see them more than i see
my
my own family really so they're they are
my second family and i really miss them
and i'm very excited to get back to work
um
yeah we're all kind of like scattered
all over the place so i haven't seen
them at all but
yeah very excited all right so you're
like a massive triple threat here
actress
singer dancer if you had to pick one
that you just connect with the most
that's hard i know this is a hard
question but
which one do you think you really
connect with the most
um you know i
would have said dancing
um years ago i that would have been my
pick for sure it's just i've
i started when i was three and it's also
it's always just been home for me but
um i would say now acting it's like
it's just it's just my life like i just
i give myself to my acting and
um yeah i don't i don't see
oh i can't see myself not doing it